we're told that ricky is going on a road
trip that is a hundred kilometers long
his average speed is 70 kilometers per
hour
at that speed he can drive five
kilometers for every liter of fuel that
he uses
fuel cost 60
60 or 0.6 dollars per liter so
equivalent of 60 cents per liter but
they wrote it as .6 dollars per liter
what is the cost of fuel for the trip
pause the video and see if you can
figure that out
all right so let's see what information
they give us they tell us that the trip
is 100 kilometers
long
they tell us that the average speed is
70 kilometers per hour
so 70
kilometers per hour
they tell us
that at that speed
we can drive or he can drive five
kilometers for every liter of fuel that
he uses so five
kilometers
per
liter
and then they tell us that fuel costs
0.60 dollars per liter
so then this last piece of information
right over here
is that fuel costs 0.60
dollars
per liter normally we would see that
written as 60 cents per liter but let's
just go with it this way so it's going
to be useful for the total cost of the
fuel for the trip
well we need to figure out how much fuel
we're going to use and then multiply
that of times the cost of the fuel so
how much fuel are we going to be using
let's see we're going
a hundred kilometers that's the total
distance
and then this tells us essentially how
many liters we're going to have to use
over those 100 kilometers now you might
say how exactly does that work well if
i'm going 5 kilometers per liter if i
were to take the reciprocal of this
information i would get one fifth of a
liter
of a liter per
kilometer
that's how much fuel i use per kilometer
one-fifth of a liter and so why is that
useful well if i take 100 kilometers
and if i were to multiply it times
one-fifth of a liter per kilometer this
is going to tell you that over the
course of this trip i am going to use a
hundred times one-fifth liters or this
is going to tell us that over the course
of the trip we are going to use 20
liters
and then if we were to multiply that
times the cost of fuel per liter well
then we know how much the cost of our
trip is so let's do that
then let's multiply this
times
0.60
dollars per liter
which is the same thing as multiplying
this times 0.60
dollars
per liter
liter the liters cancel out so it's good
that our units work out we're left with
just dollars here so 20 times 0.60
is going to get us 2
to 12. so we are left with
12.
and we're done that's the cost of our
trip and i know what you're thinking
wait we didn't use the information right
over here that he's that he's traveling
an average speed of 70 kilometers per
hour it's true we did not use it in our
calculation although it was kind of
useful because we had to know what his
fuel efficiency is at that speed so
they're saying they're traveling at 70
kilometers per hour and then at that
speed we get this fuel efficiency now
they could have just told us they didn't
even have to tell us this they could
have just told us at whatever speed he's
going his fuel efficiency is this and we
still would have been able to figure out
the total cost of the fuel for the trip